We're going to court.
It's God.
>> You thought we forgot. You hoped that we
forgot. You hoped that the drama and the
infighting would make this moment blow
over. That we would have other things to
focus on. that your embarrassment would
just blow like an old leaf in the wind
and and the next season just comes
along. Well, psych, you're wrong. You
ain't going nowhere and ain't none of us
forget. Ladies and gentlemen, in order
to keep the video suppressed as long as
he could, Muhammad Hijab has come up
with some kind of court order to keep
the video down and we would have to go
to court and I would have to win the
case in order for the video to go back
up. Boy, he does not want this video up
on the channel. He knows it. He knows
what this was doing, guys. With the
video down for the last two weeks that
has been down, our channel has exploded
since the destruction of Muhammad Joab,
his absolute embarrassment. And thanks
to you, my guy, you are the one who blew
this out of proportion. You made this so
much worse than it could have been. And
now we're going to court and it's going
to be a fun time. See, this is going to
be an example, ladies and gentlemen.
This is going to be an example for the
DA guys out there, for you weird Muslims
out there who try to use this trend to
copyright the Christians and uh put out
these false copyright claims and do
these fake accounts and coward behind
fake accounts. This is going to be an
example. You guys will no longer be
getting away with these false copyright
claims. We're going to get you. Let it
be known, Muhammad Hijab,
this is long from over. You are just
prolonging the inevitable. And so, just
for an example of a little small
victory, we have our highlight video
back up. Muhammad Hab didn't just strike
the main discussion that we had. He also
copyright struck the highlight video
that we made of his blunders and us just
absolutely roasting him and destroying
him and embarrassing him for 12 minutes
straight. You guys can go ahead and
click this and watch this. The link is
down in the description below. Make sure
you guys interact with that video. Get
the engagement back going because he
shot that video down when it was also
doing well. You can't stop us. If you
want to help out and join the battle
against Muhammad hijab so that we can
absolutely destroy him and humiliate him
for the sake of Christ, we have started
a GoFundMe account. And so if you would
like to donate to the cause, you're able
to donate through the GoFundMe which is
going to be pinned in the description
and in the comment section below. Let's
get this guy. Let's make him an example
that one, you cannot falsely copyright
strike creators, especially Christian
creators, and get away with it. And two,
we fight and we fight together.
Let's get him.
>> It's God. It's God. is God.